[Musique]
sortie monde
j'ai parlé d'un quartier qui est
particulier mais aussi j'attends d'être
maman parce que dans chaque chacune de
nos vies il ya un sens et il ya des
raisons pour lesquelles sommes en train
de vivre
mais en lieu et place des débattre sur
ce sens et son explication
je vais ici raconter une petite histoire
voilà une histoire assez personnelle
mais qui pourrait inspirer certains mais
avant de commencer
j'ai posé une question et je vous prie
d'être sincère est ce que dans la salle
y at il des personnes qui aiment
l'argent
mais les v merci beaucoup merci j'ai
commencé par un fort et sur l'argent
j'aime l'argent l'argent circule
constamment dans ma vie j'ai dépensé
d'argent avec joie il me revient
toujours multiplié les merveilleuses
façon dont l'argent est bon très bon ces
petits poèmes n'a pas fait de moi à
l'extérieur de l'argent mais plutôt
quelqu'un qui en cherchent
pour une raison particulière je ne
m'accroche pas cet argent mais j'aime a
su l'utiliser pour essayer de changer
des vies
la petite histoire commence à 6 ans je
suis né d'un père et d'une mère les deux
sont encore en vie gloire à dieu on perd
c'est l'enseignant profession
il adore l'enseignement et il dit que
c'est les métiers les plus non plus nous
sommes tous que nous sommes
grâce à nos enseignants malgré leurs
revenus masse est maigre mais ils sont
passionnés et ils n'ont pas arrêté de le
faire pour changer nos vies
même quand il regarde nos vies il
n'arrête pas de les échos qui nous
emmène au sommet
ma mère est une ménagère qui a
accompagné fortement mon père et qui
nous a aidé à changer nos vives j'ai eu
un parcours académique qui est assez
roulant d argent en plaquant avec les
amis poser la question montre préférée
il faudra que tu opèrent les gens pour
avoir de l'argent
pourquoi qui va les faire douter les
métiers parce qu'il faudrait tout
l'espace moi ce que je fais c'est
l'argent et cela explique mon travail à
la tuer je vais présenter comme un
spécial pour la moitié du pays tout
l'espace est et je suis dans l'argent
cette phase par les espèces c'est là mon
électronique et vous donner rapidement
mon parcours et je vais rentrer dans la
petite histoire de vie j'ai 40 ans je
suis marié et père
les quatre hommes étaient profondes mon
cas n'est une troisième primaire donc
j'ai l'intention d'en rajouter et je
crois que je n'ai pas maintenant pour
que les choses changent pour eux et que
les choses changent pour la communauté
vous verrez sur le thème qui devrait
afficher que j'ai décidé de parler
demain amende mais aussi de mon quartier
ce quartier s'appelle qu'il est pour
ceux qui ont vécu à kinshasa ce quartier
quartier voisin à l'université de
kinshasa où mon père a acquis un espace
de vie après qu'il ait été victime d'un
incendie dans les bas congo où il
travaillé et j'ai commencé mardi à 6 ans
et à 6 ans que j'ai est vrai souvenir
j essaie à 6 ans qui sont obligés de
faire des vrais km avec lui parce que
j'ai la chance d'étudier dans une école
du fait qu'ils vivent enseignants et moi
j'étais la gratuité c'est vrai qu'avec
sa rémunération je n'aurais pas eu la
même chance mais j'ai bénéficié de cette
gratuité
donc il faut que je me défends ce à six
ans pour être réveillé très tôt
étalé sur ses épaules à cette école
mais déjà très rapidement ça veut dire
complexe parce que la distance entre la
maison et l'école des normes
il est resté simple ne peut pas arrêter
découvrez mais l'accompagneraient tour
et quant à l'époque nous avions des
abonnements quand le combat était ce
qu'il était à 6 ans je devais me
débrouiller avec un abonnement et
prendre le bus tout seul et faire une
vingtaine de kilomètres entre à la
maison et c'est là qu'est la vraie
bataille de la vie commence les
conditions se sont encore empirer
quelques années plus tard qu'en 1995
on apprend qu'elle crée millions qui
commence on apprend que l'université et
hervé et les trois frères aînés tout ici
est changé leur vie et c'est là que j'ai
raison à la présentation padam lydien
qui fait de nouveau un bon endroit
mon endroit ces trois frères ont visité
un bon matin des prendre la carte
graphique
mon père mon père ça choquera frais
formation et j'ai été surpris en train
de déposer les potiers
j'ai posé la question mais c'est en
train de faire quoi et mon père qui me
dit tu es petit tu sais que ce temps
layton était liée aux colosses fin et
dit oui je sais non mais ce n est ce pas
alors nous nous vous parler chez eux
parce que l'université est enfermé on
sait pas quand et ça va reprendre tous
ceux qui ont de meilleures conditions
que nous aurons décidé par les pieds aux
parents et les billets partir et nous ne
l'avons pas alors nous devons pas perdre
des années
nous partons geste en laye et chez les
pistons
c'était une petite plaque c'est une
réalité oui mais c'est allé là 1995
mes frères ont quitté la maison et son
parti elle est posée la question comme
on exempté
ils ont choisi et changer leur vie par
ce chemin
aujourd'hui quand je suis atterré et que
tu apprends qu'il ya un ouvrage quelque
part je pense à eux je pose la question
comment il avait fait à l'époque mais
ils sont les leviers
ils ont fait l'équateur ils ont fait la
république centrafricaine ils ont fait
une âme héros nous ont fait le nigeria
ils ont fait le maroc
ils ont fait l'espagne et c'est en
espagne qui sont pris chacun sa
direction
exactement comme prévu trois ans après
a pris trois ans et les années sont chez
dr il fallait c'est pas trop avec les
parents à côté de jeunes search avec moi
un peu comme mes bébés mais qui est en
réalité le cadet des garçons et c'est
une vie assez assez combien ce qu'il
fallait essayer d'avoir mais j'avais la
chance d'être dans un quartier
particulier que je cite qui d'aider ce
quartier nous en tant qu'enfant ne
connaissant pas les joies des enfants ok
mais nous sommes très heureux dans ce
quartier si c'était à refaire je
rentrerai ce quartier haut quand un
réseau d'une voiture d'une des montants
m'a montré la voiture tu l'as fan des
cris ou compter la famille ces quartiers
où il n'existait pas de téléphone parce
que pour communiquer avec nos frères
veulent aller fourni
je travaille dans la télécommunication
aujourd'hui je prenais la valeur
téléphone parce que gestionnaire dans
une famille m'ont dit à vous et c'est
dans ce quartier que je rencontre les
meilleures personnes de la vie ce
quartier nous une maison n'avait pas
besoin des clôtures ce quartier pour un
voisin commencé le matin à faire sa
cuisine mais son choix ne sachant pas du
tout c'est qu'il aurait continent parce
que ces condiments vient de l'est chez
vous ce quartier on ne sait pas qui est
sorcier on ne sait pas qui a été pris en
vidéo comme ces derniers temps
et c'est une partie du milieu de premier
[Applaudissements]
et seul un quartier je dois tout et j'ai
eu un moment fantastique seulement qui
est une raison de vie pour moi qui
malgré la petitesse de la rémunération
de l'auteur n'a pas lâché et elle a été
confirmée par défi je suis dans le
business
ici on réentend travailleurs dont la
borne électronique tu n'auras gestion
mais la personne qui va appris à gérer
c'est d'abord le maire parce que très
vite avec les crises
elle a transformé le salon en une
entreprise
elle en a fait un business une sorte
plongée rivers et c'est cadeau
elle a sauté sur l'opportunité de la
proximité avec l'université pour engager
deux trois personnes qui vais déjà faire
sans doute n'est s'est vendu à
l'université
vous comprendrez que quand l'université
vers nous elle fait faillite mais elle
n'a pas lâché
parce qu'en ces moments là nous avons 18
ans et on a pris la relève et c'est là
qu'une nouvelle vie commence il faut
commencer l'université il faut vivre sur
les promesses et friandises en europe
eldorado à leur endroit ce n'était pas
forcément mon endroit
il fallait choisir
ils y allaient rester essayer des bennes
forez parce que tu es une grosse
bataille pour eux et j'ai dcid commencer
l'université
c'est un début très compliqué parce que
la première année déjà
j'attends qu'il est frais académiques
des vallées
120 dollars à l'époque mais je reconnais
que 60 et les 60 n'avait été piqué à
moitié dans la poche pour en prendre la
voie par le vendeur et j'ai pleuré comme
un enfant a donc cédé 7,62 d'appeler mon
père m'avait donné c'était la matinée
près je n'avais pas d'autre choix il
fallait trouver l'autre moitié et je me
suis mis à chercher un travail
j'avais 20 ans jeune j'avais perdu deux
années scolaires parce que j'avais fait
un accident avec ma des prix par
derrière qui va y perdre une année
scolaire et je n'ai pas perdu espoir et
j'ai foncé j'ai eu à entraîner travail
dans une radio de la place où tu
travailles ans mais les voleurs aient
été auditeur qui vont mener un petit
rien en quantité contente dans
l'émission l'année d'après je suis passé
au deuxième ceinture avec ses petits
brouillard mais j'ai trouvé un travail à
l'université je pouvais bouger d'un coin
à un autre de faire une pause rats et je
trouve une question ce qui dans la salle
en moins de 35 ans est ce que vous venez
le moment s'il vous plaît merci beaucoup
de votre est comme personne j'étais
jeune et je voulais changer la vie de ma
mère et je voulais aussi voir ce
quartier qui m'avait tout donner être
transformé je me suis dit je me battre
j'ai eu honte et les boulots dans un
centre de recherche à l'université
un prof qui était ancien ministre
d'économie du terrier qui m'a donné
l'opportunité d'apprendre
nous sommes retrouvés à six pour
rejoindre la persévérance en fait on a
fait allusion ici par cendrier gérerait
de josette équipe et un mois après cinq
personnes et est parti j'étais resté
seul parce que le professeur ne payez
pas il n'est payé pas été pas bons
payeurs
et tout cela sans parti et j'ai dit je
ne pars pas pu accepter d'apprendre
gratuitement et j'ai eu une négociation
avec le prof je le dis je vais te faire
tous les cas vaille que tu me demandera
tout ce que je demande c'est que tu veux
payer sa tête unique
j'ai signé avec lui pour que dans ce
sens avec une émotion que l'on musique
débité de son tente équivalent de mes
frais académiques et que j'ai le droit
d'accès jusqu'en deuxième naissance
ça va payer les frais de deuxième
lecture deuxième descente ses propres
intérêts en perd 3 parce qu'il m'a tout
appris des choses qui ne veut pas
apprendre à l'école juste qui peut pas
apprendre de mes parents il avait ce
qu'il fallait pour que j'apprenne et
j'avais le sacrifice et la persévérance
pour apprendre sans attente dessous mais
comme ma maman on m'avait déjà coaché
j'étais un très bon élève de ma mère en
termes de gestion d'argent comme j'aime
l'argent
j'ai commencé à m'en a créé dans son
ensemble la chaire opportunité je lui
dis comme tu te payes pas parce que tu
sais que j'utilise un ordinateur pour
donner des cours à mes propres collègues
qui les connaissent pas ce qui a en
informatique à l'époque c'était tout
pauvre en informatique il accepte ses
effectifs éléments et vous permet
d'avoir un petit rien pour avoir un
petit ami à côté
si ça ne vous inquiétez pas troisième
gratuit or s'il est vite passé je
reprends procès qui est nouveau
aujourd'hui qui chemine avec et je finis
et à la fin de cette année la deuxième
licence temps j'ai fini ses professeurs
qui partit personnel et je commence ma
carrière professionnelle comme je vous
disais tantôt j'ai 40 ans j'ai travaillé
donc appliqué national des ja
successivement pour la biat danger
commencé et après quatre ans à la bd
j'ai fait qu à trois avec tiko est mené
avec orange aujourd'hui je suis à ma
troisième année avec vodafone je crois
que ce temps du coaching
cette appartenance à mon quartier c'est
tout type de ma mère va donner quelque
chose en chaland qui m'ont permis la
donne ce que gm mais à la fin deux
raisons parce que jocelyn disaient
qu'ils me suis posé la question c'est
quoi en raison d'être
pourquoi je suis là j'ai pris mon temps
devant trévise de leadership
je me suis dit il faut que j'apporte ma
pierre mais quelques maps hier c'est
d'essayer de donner quelque chose de
stable ses parents mais aussi quelque
chose à ce quartier qui était ma façon
d'être à séparer en deux ans il ya deux
ans j'ai parlé que frère un petit coq
watts à un petit look est alors moins
génial ou bachy pour travailler quand on
sait pas qu'il se sera équipé par après
dans leur troisième âge préfère qu'il
soit à côté d'un d'entre vous êtes
partis à pied
je préfère qu'il vienne
et cette heure-là les parts au
réchauffement calello canada et isis ont
visiblement premier objectif atteint de
l'est pour des parents le cédant ce que
en arrivant ici je me suis dit qu'est ce
que je reçois par quartier j'ai crié une
équipe de foot ici vocalement qui a
commencé son championnat en 3e division
qui était l'année passée et elle a été
championne de la 3e division
[Applaudissements]
et cette année elle joue la deuxième
division en phase aller elle est aussi
championne et elle a beaucoup de chance
de serra champion de cette année pour
être en première division
ici en vous qui avez moins de 35 ans
particulièrement je voterai savons juste
pour vous dites que vos conditions
actuelles doit pas être un frein
ce que vous n'avez qu'une situation peut
être un vrai challenge
si c'était à refaire j'accepterai des
livres dans ce même quartier dans ces
mêmes conditions
parce que c'est la charge et ma vie je
n'y ai je vraiment si
[Applaudissements]